where is having a met an awesome PI data
please and some enthusiasm I know is
three yet it's past three but you're not
hearing can you hear me all right okay
so i'll try speak a bit louder okay so
10 things i learn about writing data
pipeline in python spark does it sound
familiar alright i try a try and speak
louder can you get me now okay that will
help awesome so okay so 10 things i
learned about writing data pipeline in
python spark does it sound familiar now
all right okay yeah no no it's not click
bait so so so what what is it about in
the next 30 minutes I'll I try and tell
you about a few patrons and that you can
sort of like take away and apply to your
code probably today very practical there
will be some code snippets right and and
yeah before I go into that the code
would be primarily pison to write that's
because that's what we'd use in
production at the moment so most of the
patterns would be I think should be able
to apply nicely to python 3 but maybe
some of them if you have a problem talk
to me there won't be a machine learning
right aspect of this at least at the
moment but we're sort of getting into
that use with caution the patterns that
that sort of need a bit of understanding
of the of the underlying stuff it I
would sort of throw our caution that
like put a steric on there just so you
know
yeah mostly Python I know that title
says spark as well but I had to cut it
somewhere to fit it in 30 minutes so so
a lot of spot portion may be next next
time I'll try to cover so who's this
talk far essentially you know these guys
so if you happen to if you happen to
sort of like have some basic networking
knowledge of Python it's a guy on the
right some basic working knowledge of
Python but want a sub sort of start data
wrangling in the with some real-world
data right that's this dog would benefit
you if you happen to be a scientist wink
wink I happen to be a scientist who sort
of maybe have some experience in data
wrangling in some other language but
you're just starting to use Python and
and you know picking it up and want to
sort of learn some intermediate patterns
that would benefit your code quality and
generally you know improve the
performance perhaps in some ways so it
can be you as well background so this
talk essentially draws upon my
experience in implementing the
financials pipeline at doodle so for
those of you who don't know dude ill the
best introduction perhaps at this moment
would be this story how many of you have
heard of this all right so this was done
on doodle platform what doodle does is
it provides data and insights into
private companies right publicly right
so so there's a lot of insights
available publicly and this is public
data by the way all the companies are
required to file in information about
shareholders about their finances into
the company's house it's it's it's you
know they're required to do it by law
it's just that the data is sort of like
inside a silo and and there's no way to
sort of like you know I use it and send
any sort of nice way so that's what
doodle does
mostly so quarter for last year I landed
in doodle and I picked up a project of
writing an enhanced financials pipeline
so before I got there the financials
that we had we essentially picked up
from from from companies house and
publish them almost as is on the website
the plan was to to use this treasure
trove of financial information about
companies and compute some metrics on it
right so what some some complicated
metrics maybe some trend analysis right
to sort of come up with something better
than just publishing like turnovers and
stuff like that right so this is what
the project is about essentially doodle
at this moment in time it has 11 million
companies in UK and Ireland so 11
million companies registered in UK and
Ireland we have the data for all of them
from the finance perspective they're
about approaching about hundred million
account filings for these companies
right and it the data goes back ten
years right so there's a there's a
ten-year sort of you know hopefully an
will filings from each company so it's a
it's a reasonable sized data and it's
reasonable sort of in its complication
it's a nice it's the nice data set it
looks like this so you go and do the
website you click on financials and you
get all these numbers so all of these
are like financial metrics that you can
then maybe plot so I'm plotting turnover
here against let's see net assets for
brompton how many of you are familiar
with brompton bikes I love them so you
get all this data so who would be who
would who do you think would be
interested in this sort of information
right people who are going into business
with brompton generally right do you
want to know if brompton is supposedly a
vendor or maybe your client you want to
know what are the financials what do
they look like you also want to know who
holds a who holds interest in Brompton
bikes who is the shareholder who is the
beneficiary if brompton goes does well
who would benefit right that creates
some interesting scenarios you may also
want to know if the if the director of
brompton bicycles if his wife owns
shares in a rival company we can't do
that right now but we can tell you if
the person who the director of brompton
bikes own shares in a rival cycling
company that would make it a bad
investment I guess conflict of interest
stuff like that the data so the data
comes like i told you in terms of it
basically come in terms of account and
for every account filing we have a
summary filing so sub summary account
which is on the on the far side here
then depending on the type of the
company and type of filing we have one
of these specialized accounts and
essentially what we need to do is we
need to based on some business logic we
need to pick different fields from
different accounts to make up a standard
data set that's the first step right so
once you have that standard data set
nailed you can calculate some metrics
some simple metrics right so based on
certain field in the data set you can
calculate some more complicated metrics
that are more related to people what
people are interested in then you can do
some trend metrics right so you can
reinvest the data based on like a time
series and you can you can sort of do
some sort of trend analysis on these
metrics and and this is where we are at
right now going forward of course you
can you can then play you can start
playing right so this if you're getting
into this right now so you can start you
can make all of this data searchable
based on metrics you can segment
companies so so it's a very interesting
problem like if I happen to be like a
company with turnover between 10 to 20
million and the keywords that apply to
me our technology 3d printing London
stuff like that what would be how am i
doing amongst my peers
what who would be my peers and how do i
how men performing with in that sort of
segment right so that segmenting is it's
an interesting problem and benchmarking
as well and and you can do all sort of
like you know more advanced analysis
once you have in this you know once you
are in this position 22 but I want you
to it so this is the forest right but I
want you to really zoom in into the into
the tree now so for for calculating a
simple metric I'm going to just pick one
right and I'm going to sort of take you
through that process right how does the
how does the code look like what can we
do to to do this in a more beautiful way
let's talk about gearing it's one of the
financial metrics Goering is essentially
it's it's it's sort of signifies to what
extent that company's operations that
dependent upon its the loans that it has
taken versus the that sort of investment
it has drawn right so you know you
probably in good times you would want to
have more of this so remote that that
dies more of this something like that it
gives you a nice it's a simple function
it's really uh you know liabilities you
/ shareholder funds x 100 that an end of
it right that's it that's the
computation if you if you look at the
pure computation that that's it right
but that's not always it right and and
hit here's where the fun starts so of
course you you're not because of the way
this function is called you cannot
consume specific arguments you have to
consume like a record that sort of
essentially a you know a filing of a
count or something a standard account
and you have to sort of like of course
you know it's like a dictionary so you
can you can sort of indexed the
variables from it but but notice the
notice the yellow code here notice how
it grows right so little bits right so
so here here goes the local variables
then a source because it's real world
data you can never rely
I for both of these so one of these to
be a floating point they're supposed to
be but they almost you know it's pretty
random often both of these would come
out as integers and if you know basic
Python you know that you know it divided
two integers results in an integer it
floors it I drops the floating-point so
you need to sort of like x 1 point 0 to
make sure that the denominator like you
know the numerators thought stays a
floating point is to ensure that's a
floating point so that's then of course
you do not guarantee that these fields
would be part of the record right so you
have to first check if they are actually
inside the record and and and you start
getting into if statements but hold on
there's more of course you can't you
have no guarantee that the denominator
here can't be a zero and if you don't
check for that it would result in a zero
the event division error and break your
pipeline right you don't want to do that
so of course if there's the shareholder
funds here 0 you cannot calculate
gearing should return on and but there's
more there's absolutely no guarantee
that one of these fields will not be
none right and this is a crazy part
because we get this data and a lot of
these fields they have like you know the
alternate between 0 and nulls like you
have to sort of really get into the you
know get into it to to find out where 0
and now are actually different what is
the difference right they sort of use it
alternatively almost randomly it's like
it's completely crazy but yeah so where
is the computation gone and this is a
simple function this is like it's as
simple as it gets right there much more
complicated metrics functions much more
variables much more checks a simple
function is just like it just flooded
with data cleaning staff and the
computation is lost so imagine for a guy
six months later some buck comes up
opens up this code hoping to find the
gearing function staring at him
and he gets this so then I'm first take
away the cleaning code but these are
pretty opinionated but but bear with me
cleaning code will eventually eat
compute good and your code quality and
totally I mean yeah so but but not if we
can do something about it it's Python
after all right so so you should be it
should be able to there's a reason why
we use Python things should be able to
do something about it and let's start
with this annoying little one point 0
for starters it's annoying because in a
file filled with these type of functions
like say a hundred functions if you do
it this way you're going to miss three
or four right and that is going to come
up in the data set later the process
data in some crazy sort of ways because
these metrics are not just things are
not stopping here on calculating gering
there would be a metric could be using
gearing to calculate something else and
you're missing the whole you know if you
miss this one point though you're
missing the whole floating-point part of
the computation itself so what can we do
about it because it's Python to this is
it this is this is a from so you can do
this right essentially what it does is
it overrides the the classical Python
division and so that when you divide two
numbers irrespective of their integer
afloat the result is guaranteed to be a
float right and it's been around for a
while but it's it's so it's not as
common in the wild as as it should be
it's in fact it's it's a pep 238 right
and the conversation that you look this
up the conversation that goes beneath
this in the in the pep it is amazing
this it's like yeah it's pretty so
disabled pythons default integer
division as the pep 2.38 lays it out
it's essentially not very intuitive
right so you can do this
but be very there's a steric there all
right the way this is coded if you don't
put it anywhere except the top of the
file it would raise an exception and
complain right but it doesn't permeate
through the modules right so if you're
using some API function in there it
won't because it's you know right so it
won't go to that the functionality will
not you know permeate for everything
down below right it's only for this file
that this applies right which is not a
problem because you don't get a P is for
calculating earrings so most of the code
here is pure anyway moving forward so
yeah this is a simple one you can you
can sort of like of course you're
checking 40 right but python is a
language of consenting adults right so
you can make a mistake and say sorry
it's called exceptions and yeah but
that's yeah that's like try catching
exception it's a zero division exception
here in hundred functions in a file
probably because it's pie time probably
we expect to do better right what is
happening here is a decorator in right
and the decorator is pretty simple you
can actually sort of look at this code
later I don't want to I don't want you
to go through this but the decorator
what it does is it catches 0 division
errors now this is a blasphemy almost in
Python terms but because of the because
of the domain that we're operating in
and you have like hundred two hundred
functions in which you have to sort of
like check for every signal denominator
being zero it's highly likely to make a
mistake it's better to do it this way
because double steric here handle 0
division error in decorators double
steric 0 division error itself is a very
specific exception it's not it's not
like you're consuming ty better it's not
the same thing it's very specific you
can get away with this but with caution
because of the way exceptions bubble the
call trace this would consume the
exceptions that are raised in API
functions that you call
your code as well be very much moving
forward so now I mean so as I just sort
of already put forward I hate I hate
looking up the I hate the dictionary
syntax that's going on in here I really
don't like it I'm having to do this
because because of you know easing the
function where this is called from I'll
show you the code as well later but I
want to get rid of this what you can do
here is is you can essentially you can
essentially use the star star dictionary
unpacking in Python so instead of
calling this like gearing record you
would call it gang carrying stars Carey
Codd right and that would what that
would do is that would unpack the
dictionary of record into the local
arguments here and why is this keyword
argument here so the shareholder funds
and the liabilities would go in the
local variables respectively everything
else would be would be consumed by the
keyword arguments history either won't
break right but there's a problem it
still won't work can somebody tell me
why
make sense awesome you can now that the
added advantage of using this pattern is
that you can now sort of like shift some
of the some of the conditionals out into
the default argument values right so
that sort of texture and look at the
function now it's looking so much better
it's not getting to the side that's
supposed to be yeah thank my you know my
future six months L would would thank me
for doing this so another takeaway that
you can use the dictionary unpacking to
your advantage of course what else now
I'm obsessive compulsive now I want to
like take it back to the way it was
right before i started doing all the
data cleaning stuff i really want to get
rid of this but i cannot i mean i can do
try but what exception would it raise if
i encounter none in an arithmetic
expression does anybody know type error
right typer you don't want to consume
type errors in your because typer is
like a very generic exception it happens
like in 30 different cases right you
don't want to have a decorator there
that does type what can we do um you
know alright so that was
did I miss something yeah I miss
something sorry I'll this derp you can
do something like this and again the
code is available so I don't wanna I
don't want you to read through every
line here but what you need to do what
you need to just look at is the fact
that I'm not consuming the I'm not not
consuming the type error here what I'm
doing is using something called inspect
module that allows you to I trade over
the I've trade over the local variables
that are passed in a function so you can
check for each one of them being none
and so it's not the same as as as
handling and consuming a type error it's
a bit different much more cleaner but
yeah I won't say you do you go and do
that so it's good to be a craftsman but
but don't be a perfectionist but
somebody recognize this from somewhere
no it was Lauren so so okay you okay but
but I'm trying to practice what I preach
here the whole of the presentation is in
is in grayscale but this I this isn't
powerful this is color right so I'm not
being a perfectionist because if i miss
the color here you would miss the joke
with you almost anyway but yeah don't be
don't be don't be don't fall prey to
obsessive compulsive you know things
right one of the lessons learned let's
step back a bit let's talk about how it
all fits together right what is the I'm
going to switch to that screen for a
while all right yeah I love you too I
love you all as well right so it's not
the so the function with these little
computational kernels will call from
calc metrics let's say that so without
having without passing in the record
itself right if I were to you know do it
very simply I would end up like writing
like I don't know 400 500 lines of code
to to pass in each sort of the right
argument to this function but because i
was able to consume the record right I
could do it like this
so there would be a mapping dictionary
that gives me the name of the field that
I'm about to calculate and the function
that I'm using to calculate it and and
that's it that's the calling function
itself is in all of its entirety right
three lines of code the three lines of
code you loop over this right you just
call the function that's it pure and
simple and obviously this count sets
code as well but there is code and
there's cold the dictionaries the config
style dictionaries are the letter type
my product my product owner is happy to
edit a config history right yeah so
mapping dictionaries are awesome use
more of them so ok let's let's talk a
bit about the trend metrics I'm running
out of time here but so it's a similar
side mapping dictionary that i'm using
here but so this is what i want to talk
about so this is this is a very standard
sliding window function that is I taken
probably it sits on Python documentation
for 480 tools i believe so traditionally
what you would do is you would use a
default argument to sort of ease the use
of the API so most of the time this
would be called it would be for size 2
because you want the current account and
the previous account and you want to
like that's the default size a value
that you're going to pass in so you
assign it a default argument and you say
that hey so that I've eased the IV's the
most frequent case right that that's
easier to use now but what you can you
can do better actually did this would be
how it would be called so for to you get
away without specifying the size with
three is specify the size you can use
partials how many of you have used
partials ok enough whew um but you can
use partial what partial does is it's
sort of it's sort of lets you make new
functions out of your slide
window function that have some arguments
pinned to a certain value right and that
sort of is a very nice self-documenting
way of having functions like short shot
guts for for calling frequent cases and
that covers more than a single frequent
case right so the default argument only
covers for size equals two but this
covers for as many and these are single
liners so it's not a it's not a great
pain to have them as well use partials
make your API is more accessible all
right so we are running into how many of
you recognize this as a problem in
Python awesome too well oh that's great
34 awesome closures right so can anybody
guess what the output would be if i run
this
yep
so okay this would be the output how
many of you find this surprising to all
right this is what you need to do to get
the output that you want it right this
is because of closures and late binding
in Python if you want to talk more about
this I'll be available after you talk
but but yeah i'll share the links as
well common common problem in Python
right this is common it's a common
gotcha for new comers so be aware of
common python watches right there's a
there's a book I think hitch guide
hitchhiker guides to python or something
it has a whole section on this it's very
useful to be aware of these things what
would happen here speak up
easy yeah you're taking it slow like god
complex no simple problem what would
happen here brilliant awesome so what am
I doing here if i'm specifying the type
of these numbers as flood type nothing
right there floats yes no yes this is
what i'm going to get so i load them up
in an RDD i collect them again can you
see the difference the way these numbers
and interesting isn't it so if this
showed up on your website somehow the
very few people who would you know I
know a lot of people from sea background
who would immediately get this what's
happening here but very few people like
two or more into scripting languages
they sort of realize common coding
gotchas what's happening here is the
Python default real number type although
it says is float if you're coming in
from a sea background you tune find out
this double and not looked so if you
just put in like float here it will
break stuff put in double and it will
work right it has to do with the I
Triple E like single float single
procedure and double precision stuff
don't yeah so be aware of common coding
gotchas this is an example but what you
need to do is to sort of light if you
have a general awareness about what is
the common sort of the journal of very
nice off when you when you sort of see
that this number supposed to end in 24
suddenly start ending in 64 that there's
some bit turn truncation happening right
yeah such an odd number yeah I mean a
person is not into coding would never
get by 256 right surprised at that yeah
so finally so this is the documentation
for the project that I'm telling you
about the financial stuff and what I
want to take away from this is that this
is a spreadsheet it's it's I watering in
its detail right we actually really sat
down for a month didn't write a single
piece of code nail down this specs right
so it's a common cliche but bonus point
nothing beats awesome specs right for
such projects better sit down first and
decide what you want to go right before
you actually start coding yeah so I work
for doodle like I told you and if you're
sort of interested in this sort of stuff
so the really exciting new project that
i can tell you about is we're we're
looking now that we're now looking at
exposing structural relations between
companies and directors so if you're
looking at you know so how are two
companies private companies can be
related to each other right so maybe
they share a director maybe they share a
shareholder maybe they share maybe they
go and invest together in some other
company so maybe they have a similar
sounding name like tesco plc and text on
mobile and stuff like that maybe they
co-locate and all of these different
cases where they can be related right
and that sort of is ending up in a huge
graph like a big number of edges and we
are beginning to analyze that beginning
to find sort of insights on on you know
related companies so it's interesting
projects if you're if you're interesting
this type of stuff do visit this page
yeah I'm question time
yeah so no at this moment in time we
didn't benchmark this right because um
to be very honest we didn't need to on
that sort of scale because this is
running on 128 North cluster so I'm ver
being very so yeah we don't know but
yeah I know what you're yeah referring
to yep are you what's your
yeah yeah sorry so so he's asking that
these all of this information is if it's
available publicly on companies house
then with respect to do deal what is the
what is the angle here how I mean are we
a reseller so okay so the answer to that
this information is publicly available
but the insides aren't all right so for
instance if you want to I mean the data
itself that company house furnishes very
raw very basic if you want to do any
insights on this so we are now at this
moment consuming from 30 different data
sources and then matching this this
information so for instance if you if
you just pick up like a random account
from company house for argos we're going
to go and get a logo from somewhere
we're going to go and get social sort of
social media insights from somewhere
gonna go some new sources and do do some
sentiment analysis on that to sort of
like you know and all that stuff so it's
much more than just purely companies has
information
oh yeah so how often do we get data
digitized right but it's digitized by a
manually sort of process by by scraping
PDF and stuff so that's where the
anomaly is coming from but that's the
best we can do with respect to the
frequency of on which we are getting
this data the frequency had at this
moment in time you're operating on is we
run this whole pipeline the whole that
day the consumption the financials the
analytics and everything once per week
and it takes something like two or three
days right to run this we are now
working on making it daily right because
the data is available that the diffs
that sort of like the new data is
available daily right so we can and Tory
consume daily and go from there to a day
yeah which is sort of like for this type
of information and and this is only from
the data from companies house so if a
new story breaks out about a company
it's a different source so maybe the
financials would stay the same for the
moment because the company hasn't
reported it but the new story would
still show up and it would sort of
effect you know the whole sort of
profile of the company so they're
different data sources operate on
different frequencies yeah
um yeah I mean there are sort of
internal tools but essentially what we
are trying to do going forward is to
sort of like focus on the website as the
as the medium that we are going to work
with partially the related company stuff
that I'm telling you about that that was
a challenge to do it on the website to
actually do all the sort of like
reporting and the visualization there
but we have been able to do that so so
it looks it looks at okay strategy for
now yeah yeah at this moment in time we
have the data for you gain knowledge
online companies but as of light a few
months back we now have data for 12
European countries so that would sort of
8x our data data sort of size and we're
going to be we're going to be providing
the similar sort of insights about
European companies as well so the
language the way we are getting this
data from that is from an EU sort of
standardized so it's it's English I mean
there are obviously Unicode stuff like
the characters in there that would be
challenging but essentially the data
itself is ice consumable yeah more
cheers oh sorry so he's asking if we
also expose an API for that you can
program it weekly sort of access yes
there's an API yeah cool oh sorry
no no no no but in the company house
essentially just provides the very basic
first auto data right here's the company
here's the name of the shareholders
sometimes here's the email of the
shareholders if you're lucky here the
financials hair the audit files there
you go that's it everything else like
segmentation it's actually occurs after
we process the data and we have the
financial so if you wanna like find out
which companies are technology 3d
printing London ec2 and have a turnover
of greater than 5 million but that stuff
happens later much later yeah all lots
of lots of effort here just like
excedrin tia it's a huge job because of
the because of the corner cases right so
it seems simple but as I showed you the
code sort of like it just by dealing
with the corner cases it just grows like
it consumes like a ninety percent of the
code a very simple function is about the
cleaning of the data and only ten
percent of all the actual processing and
stuff so yeah any questions no more
cool